>> President Trump: WHEN I
MAKE PROMISES, I KEEP THEM.
I AM ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT THE
UNITED STATES WILL WITHDRAW FROM
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE FACT IS, THIS IS A HORRIBLE
ONE-SIDED DEAL THAT SHOULD HAVE
NEVER, EVER BEEN MADE.
IT DIDN'T BRING CALM, IT DIDN'T
BRING PEACE, AND IT NEVER WILL.
IN THE MEANTIME, POWERFUL
SANCTIONS WILL GO INTO FULL
EFFECT.
IF THE REGIME CONTINUES ITS
NUCLEAR ASPIRATIONS, IT WILL
HAVE BIGGER PROBLEMS THAN IT HAS
EVER HAD BEFORE.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PULLING THE U.S. OUT OF THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL, SWIFT REACTION.
EUROPEAN ALLIES RELEASING A
STATEMENT TOGETHER.
IT IS WITH REGRET AND CONCERNED
THAT WE TAKE NOTE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECISION TO
WITHDRAW THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA FROM THE JCPOA.
TOGETHER WE EMPHASIZE OUR
CONTINUING AGREEMENT >>
AGREEMENT TO THE AGREEMENT,
REMAINING IN PLACE FOR SECURITY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO AVOID TAKING
ACTION WHICH OBSTRUCTS
LIMITATIONS TO ALL OTHER PARTIES
TO THE DEAL, AND NOT ALL
COUNTRIES SHARING THAT.
SAUDI ARABIA TWEETING OUT, THE
KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA FULLY
SUPPORTS THE MEASURES TAKEN BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH JCPOA.
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD CONCERNS IN
REGARDS TO THE MISSILE PROGRAM
AND IRAN SUPPORT FOR TERRORISM.
SIMILAR STATEMENTS COMING FROM
THE UAE, BUCK RAIN, THE GOD >>
GULF ALLIES AND ISRAEL.
MATT SCHLAPP, CONTRIBUTING OR
THE HILL.
AND ELI LAKE, COLUMNIST FOR
BLOOMBERG VIDEO.
ELI, LOOKING AT LOOKING AT
ACROSS THE BOARD, THE WORLD
REACTION, YOUR TAKE ON THIS AND
THE HOPES THAT PERHAPS, YOU
HEARD THE SECRETARY OF STATE >>
TREASURIES SAY, THERE MAY BE
RENEGOTIATION?
>> THERE IS ALSO THE PERIOD OF
90-180 DAYS, AND THERE ARE NOW
NEGOTIATIONS THAT I GUESS HAVE
BEEN ANNOUNCED BETWEEN IRAN AND
THE EUROPEAN ALLIES.
SO FAR THERE HAVE NOT BEEN ANY
KIND OF CLEAR STATEMENTS FROM
THE IRANIANS, THOSE TWO THINGS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BEGIN
ENRICHING BEYOND THE LIMITS ON
URANIUM AND BUILDING UP THEIR
PROGRAM, OR KICKING OUT
INSPECTORS.
ALL OF THAT IS PRETTY GOOD.
I THINK IN SOME WAYS, IT COULD
BE A CONTINUATION OF THE
STRATEGY THAT TRUMP HAS PURSUED
REALLY SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
HIS PRESIDENCY, WHICH IS TO TRY
TO RENEGOTIATE A BETTER DEAL.
BUT THERE IS A PARADOX IN WHAT
HE SAID TODAY WHICH IS THAT HE
REALLY MADE A VERY CLEAR
STATEMENT OF SOLIDARITY WITH THE
IRANIAN PEOPLE AND THE QUESTION
IS, IF TRUMP NEGOTIATES A
BARGAIN WITH THE IRANIAN REGIME,
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE THE
IRANIAN PEOPLE?
THAT'S A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO
BEGIN THINKING ABOUT WAYS TO
SUPPORT THE DEMOCRACY MOVEMENT
WHICH HAS BEEN GAINING MOMENTUM
SINCE LATE DECEMBER IN IRAN.
>> Bret: EXACTLY, THOSE
BEGINNING IS ESSENTIALLY ABOUT
THE WEAKENING ECONOMY IN IRAN.
HERE IS IRAN REACTING.
>> [INTERPRETER]
TONIGHT WE WITNESS AND
EXPERIENCE, THE SAME THING THAT
WE HAVE SAID AND REPEATED FOR 40
YEARS HAS HAPPENED.
IRAN IS A COP >> COUNTRY THAT IS
LOYAL TO ITS COMMITMENTS AND THE
U.S. AS A COUNTRY THAT NEVER
STICKS TO ITS COMMITMENTS.
>> Bret: MATT, YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT?
EVEN IF THE U.S. CAN'T KEEP ITS
INTERNATIONAL DEALS, HOW DOES
U.S. CAN KEEP AGREEMENTS?
>> AND THERE IS OF COURSE NO
FUTURE BETWEEN AN AMERICAN
BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP IN IRAN.
WE HAVE TO LOOK PAST THAT TO THE
FUTURE.
IT'S ABOUT THE IRANIAN PEOPLE
WHO IN MANY WAYS ARE ALIGNED
LIKE NO OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
REGION TO ACTUALLY BE IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY COULD BE
ALIGNED WITH US ON SEVERAL KEY
ISSUES.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WILL NEVER GET
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FACT
THAT WE GOT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS ARRANGEMENT WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA, BUT IT DOES
SICK >> KNOCKED THE SECOND BIG
PILLAR OUT OF THE LEGACY.
NOW THERE ARE WAYS IN WHICH IT
CAN BE NEGOTIATED, BUT THE
PREMISE IS DEAD.
WHEN YOU HAVE JOHN BOLTON AND
SECRETARY POMPEO IN THERE, GREAT
THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
>> Bret: YOU HAVE SOME
DEMOCRATS OUT THERE SAYING THIS
IS THE WRONG MOVE, THE NEXT STEP
IS NOT SET IN STONE.
OBAMACARE AND REPEAL AND REPLACE
IT, BUT HERE ARE SOME DEMOCRATS
ABOUT THIS DEAL AS IT CAME TO
PASS.
>> WE SHOULD NOT GO FORWARD WITH
THIS AGREEMENT.
>> THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THE
NEGOTIATION WAS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WOULD BE NO PATHWAY FOR
IRAN TO ACHIEVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
CAPABILITY.
AND AT THIS DEAL DOESN'T ACHIEVE
THAT.
>> I'VE SAID MORE TIMES THAN I
CAN COUNT THAT I OPPOSED THE
DEAL WHEN IT WAS ANNOUNCED.
>> OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE ALL SAYING
DIFFERENT THINGS.
NOW WHAT ABOUT THIS MOVEMENT?
>> THIS WAS A FLAWED AGREEMENT
FROM DAY ONE, AND THERE WERE
CRITICS ON BOTH SIDES, THAT'S
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE SENIOR
MEMBERS ON CAPITOL HILL, HOUSE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN, SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE WHO ARE
REPUBLICANS, VERY WORRIED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT YOU GET OUT OF
THIS DEAL AND YOU ARE LEFT IN A
PERILOUS PLACE.
VERY DIFFICULT, AND IT MAKES THE
CHALLENGE WITH NORTH KOREA MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT AND IT CREATES A
WHOLE HOST OF PROBLEMS AND
CONSEQUENCES IN THE YEARS TO
COME.